hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft now before
I get back into this episode I'm
actually going to time-lapse something
and you're gonna see the wondrous
wonders of my ability to do game stuff
I'll be back okay
alright I'll be back alright look seeing
just time-lapse this because I'm about
to go I'm about to go deep and I mean
that both literally and figuratively I'm
about I have like no wood god I'm such a
tit don't you better have started that
time-lapse you seen you better start at
the time laughs I do not need people
seeing this I do not need people seeing
me fail to make a pickaxe I don't need
it none of us need it so just get on
these shears
I'll need ladders maybe fixing at the
time laughs it started right place two
copies all right no I don't think I need
the X but I'll take it anyway just good
all right okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh oh-ho-ho oh okay all right good
that's what I was hoping for actually so
what I'm doing I'm making a very nice
very well-organized and very well
thought out and mineshaft ah okay
Oh woody woody woody woody woody woody
woody woody so that's good uh do I have
gravel yes cobblestone oh why do I keep
doing that okay doing kiss
Uncas join kiss Uncas is done Oh BAM
boom BAM okay this is great actually
this is actually great it's not just
hypothetically great it's a little
creepy but it's it's pretty great why's
our light coming out of here please do
not go
Jesus Christmas how are you doing bat
and you good all right cool good good to
hear why is there light coming from here
Hey no thank you
that's what I thought no no no no no no
no no no you don't wanna all right there
we go cool all right okay
back can you go away I'm trying to
concentrate uh I think I see lots of
monsters down there and I heard a noise
that I haven't heard before
okay so that's interesting well dad I
was kind of like I'm or something but I
do know it okay so what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to make a good mine that's
gonna be like a base to start expanding
out to everything you know what I mean
ooh I've got new recipes I've got new
recipes what do I have blue dye that's
not it's not ideal a blue bed great is
that really the extent to what I can
make that's God it is okay I really
can't make a lot of crap my recipe book
is not not exactly thorough can I please
get I didn't bring more sticks all right
look so you start the time lapse back up
because I'm gonna I'm gonna carve I'm
gonna carve this out a little bit I just
want to get a nice steady mine I just
want some it's my
craft after all it's supposed to be nice
and organized and everything's supposed
to be lovely and you know how it is
right you know you know what's up I see
you know what's up all right I guess so
we've that's a lot of love possible
boozy back down time lapse engage go
oops
[Music]
oh Jesus
hi who's stepping who step stepping and
why I have connected the tunnel yes I
did somehow managed to connect these
right up wait what this isn't where I
just was this is somewhere else entirely
this is where I dig oh that's where I
dug the hole right I had entirely
forgotten about my stupid hole
[Music]
Oh God
Oh cold gold gold gold
I'm rich la will ooze ela
that doesn't sell family friendly when I
say that when I shot that out loud I
think is less less friendly less family
[Music]
I find Dimond I feel bad I feel bad I
feel bad I feel worse
no I feel worse
[Music]
am I not deep enough am i not deep
enough is that what the problem is am I
not deep enough I don't even know how to
get back to my shaft how am I gonna be
able to get deep enough where did I come
from
where did I go where did I come from
cotton-eye Joe I feel like I came this
way I'm lost
oh no oh god there's so many no please
not like this you can't you can't you
can't you can't oh you can not I don't
have much on this sword left one sweet
hit ow
too sweet ow okay yeah fight each other
yeah fighty
ow Jesus they're fair oh they're very
deadly oh man there we go there we go is
turn the tables table turns the
turntables oh god no no no no no no oh
God alright fine Oh Andy what are you
doing down there bendy what are you
doing is this where I came from I'm
trying to find where I came from where
did I come from why would I put torches
down and knock out the iron why have I
done that just someone else put torches
down here someone else down here with me
am i certain to go mine madness we're
starting to lose it oh that's the cavern
I remember going down the cavern okay I
think what I got to do is I gotta kill
this Enderman that's the only solution
to my problem yeah yeah yeah yeah you
think you you think you think you don't
know oh that's what you get that's what
you get that's what you get this would
you be
hate that so much when did to win in the
fresh hell did they turn minecraft into
a horror game good god frickin scarier
than the horror games I've ever played
why horrifying I don't need it I don't
want it I thought three I thought three
picks axes would have been enough to go
find myself diamond buye hey barely not
yeah
get off the ceiling it's nothing there
is nothing here there's just nothing
it's just an eternity of nothing I get
nothing I get nothing
do it I dare you
yeah that's what you get my pickaxe is
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm so lost
here's the shaft this is the shaft so
where's this go oh my god I found it
this is definitely it this is it this is
it this is it this is it this is it this
is it this is what I mean yes baby
I don't know why I went that stupid way
that was really dumb of me okay
time lapse over that was good
it's like why is this guy pitch black oh
it's night I forgot night happens God
just let me go to sleep edge no I want
today to be over all right so I went on
an eternal quest to get some like I was
hoping to get like one diamond I was
over to get like one turns out I got
none and turns out that I got an ungodly
no no no an ungodly amount of iron and
Gold and coal which is great however
it's not what I wanted
funny enough not what I wanted not what
I asked for not what I was gonna do not
what I came for not why I'm here but hey
I was down there so long all of my wheat
is ready to be harvested
was it not ready was it is there not Mac
is it no that that that's what it is
know that you can't fool me
no it's not ok all right I think I
thought maybe maybe not
[Laughter]
[Music]
great perfect I live in a hole in ground
I live in a hole in the ground I live in
a hole in the ground I live in a hole I
have a one-bedroom that's like 2 square
feet I live in a hole in the ground of
an hole in the ground I live in a hole
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
you know why I'll tell you why I'll tell
you why right now I'm not gonna live
like this I'm not gonna live like this
because I will not be the hermit that
lives in a cave in a hole in the ground
I will not be that hermit this should be
my excavation bit this should be my mind
this should not be my home my home
should yes I see it now I see it I can
see it I see it I see it I see my home I
see what it can be and I see what it
will become I see it now I am gonna make
my home time lapse re-engage
[Music]
yeah okay da-da-da-da-dah this is where
everyone starts applauding because this
is gonna be my house oh yeah you didn't
see that coming did you
I've never built I have never once
actually attempted to build a house how
do I make stairs how do i dude I thought
that would have been it thought that
would have been eight I thought that
would've been a stair cuz I want to make
a fancy roof I want to make a fancier
roof all right okay okay okay all right
I just want to make sure no mobs or I
want to make sure no mobs are spawning
up in here
yes it's gonna be great it's gonna be
the best keep glass for the windows and
it's gonna be it's gonna be so classy
actually no no not right there there and
there
perfect there's gonna be a beaut this
place is gonna be a beaut okay so that's
that's good so so far and I'll decorate
it with gold bread bread oh no I read
cake
bread bread bread bread Oh course Brad
brah I'm paid Brad guys I'm gonna do it
guys look at me look at me look at me it
doesn't look good at all uh don't look
at me don't look at me look at me yeah
why am I even bothering to do like Jason
they don't make no sense but there's
yeah oh I don't like that looks good
look guys I'm not a designer
I don't do the designing I got birch
doors I mean three somehow what are you
doing I don't know you
oh wait boom boom it's a beaut and a
half it's a beaut it's a beaut it's a
birch was an act
Oh get out of my home get out of my home
uh-uh get out of my home this land and
sea kind of like tucks into the the the
the the the natural landscape I didn't
want to like get rid of it I can't make
it like a waterfall
look it's waterfall I don't look nearly
as good as I wanted it to it's not
nearly as Cluj tastic where'd my where'd
my sloosh bucket go where's my bucket
excluse where's my sluice bucket Wow
Gumby my sluice bucket all right hey hey
hey hey No get out of here you orrible
monster
oh I've never had a water feature before
I don't like this outcropping here that
there yeah there yeah yeah oh yeah look
at this look at this and weep have you
ever seen something so beautiful no
exclus there we go that's what I was
open for that's more of the water
feature let's let's justify let's
justify this motion here let's justify
this motion Oh singing Mario is gonna
look at it looks terrible it a really
really bad porch all right my guys my
design is not my passion I just want you
all to know that I shoot the neighbors
they really come from far away to mess
with me what are you doing unit used to
be this aggressive did you get away from
me don't hit me don't touch me with your
filthy hands whoosh there we go that's
that's a nice tiered shoot all right
hang on
I know spider I know I'll be there shut
up shut up I'm better than you shut up I
love it yeah it's kind of ugly not gonna
lie it's kind of this a little ugly yeah
where did the shape go wrong what is it
where's our hole don't leave a hole in
there what are you doing don't leave a
hole stop be less dumb
honey is why this right oh you're in my
home you bastard get Oh Oh on double
touch me
don't judge me Oh I think the problem is
that it's clue she's out of it too much
I need to focus the solution that's the
problem there yeah this squash right
here whose clue she it's a problem why
is that it stop stop stop stop
you will you will stop you must stop
this is this is harassment
oh then your natural inclusion look you
you die than I did
that's shame zombie bastards just stay
away from my home I'm making a water
feature okay that looks better you stay
away you stay away from my water feature
if you blow up if you blow up even a
little bit of my water feature I'm gonna
be so mad don't blow up my water feature
do not know I've got it's fine actually
I think it improved it where are you
coming from where you coming from
topping you just let me blow and I
should have gone to sleep hey you all I
hate you all so much I hate oh my god
hello yes
you don't sure sure why not more more
merrier Mary more rude we'rewe're that's
a good water feature that's stupid
gosh darn creeper you do not blow up my
water feature yes I'm looking right at
you you get drift over here so I can
hate you I hate ya gonna hate ya I'm
gonna hit ya no you better not
this is the worst three hits is what it
takes right my water feature my water
feature
I didn't the problem is I don't I'm in
but I kind of looks good but I think
because his base is not rock it needs
like rock but it looks kind of it looks
okay you know what it's fine is the
thing it's fine it looks great actually
it looks really good it looks really
good is the what how do I make it look
good oh no is this bad it's a bad is
that as bad as the thing is bad D off
and let nature take its course
Oh cut off the flow real quick okay
let's cut the flow and now let's open
the flow back up see what happens okay
all right sure no cut the flow start the
flow oh the flow the flow all the
flashier I'm done you know I'm done I'm
done messing with it get out of here all
right I'm done I'm done messing with it
so bad so bad it looks so bad God look
at that it looks so bad it looks so bad
all right it's beautiful it's beautiful
it's beautiful and I love it all right
so I need sand to make glass thankfully
there's some sand here oh my god I'm so
sad I'm just like depressed now I can't
believe my mood went that far down that
fast I just can't believe the
precipitous drop of my emotions in that
moment okay I'm gonna put this glass in
the furnace I'm gonna get this cook in
so they can get some clay it's this is
glass right I'm pretty sure that's glass
we got that we're good we're happy I'm
happy I'm gonna get glass in my house
it's gonna look so good everyone's gonna
want to go there except the monsters
won't because they suck the breath of
death doing here order the whisper of
demise in my ear no I didn't order that
that's funny didn't didn't do that lass
why does that take you so long hurry up
you bastard new recipes ooh what do I
have nothing there's nothing here
it said there was something and then
there's nothing if anything I lost
recipes I don't know why what I have
alright whatever it's it's fine it's
fine you know why it's fine you know
it's fine because I have my glorious
Windows dish dish dish
[Music]
wait if I make a button that's one of
them how do I get it to do both
oh no I'm thinking about mechanics no no
oh no oh no how do I how would I do that
oh no stop
mark Breen mark brain no think good no
how would I do that it's redstone
probably but I don't know redstone I
never do redstone I never needed to know
redstone I just yelled for zombie Boldin
zombie ball that would make everything
happen for me I never had one sad to
think critically about what minecraft
actually was I never once not once and I
still don't want to but I feel now that
I might have to oh no no I have to think
critically tell me I'll figure it out on
my own you know that's how that's how
the pioneers of Minecraft figured stuff
out that's how the Wild West figured it
out there weren't guides for the people
that we're playing this first you know
what I mean they really they really knew
they knew how to tango I forgot that I
have to go to my crafting table for a
lot of my recipes shield
okay good news is I'm gonna start moving
things into my home and in doing so I'll
start making this house a home open of
my various ovens would be my ovens okay
okay that's a beaut that's a beaut right
there that's a beaut isobutyl that's a
beaut I should be raw - you boot y'all
gonna see the magic unfold before your
eyes you're gonna see it buh buh buh buh
buh buh boom boom okay a little more a
little more come on split you head no no
glass I need you Oh looks good yeah
looks good gasps that's a box it's
brilliant maybe a little more
artistically inclined but hey you know
this is it's none that roof but this is
probably the most effort I've ever put
into it any building anything it's game
forever and ever
okay dad pretty good all right okay god
damn it but I'm gonna put a bed in there
I'm gonna sleep in here okay so that's
all the time that I got for this episode
here thank you
no leave no not here there's nowhere
we're sleeping thank you everybody so
much for watching I accept no criticism
I accept no criticism constructive or
otherwise about my beautiful roof so I
can see the stars at night it's it's
glorious yes it works okay thank you
everybody I now no longer live in a hole
in the ground everyone should be happy
for me so thank you
more minecraft in the description check
out clothes brand comm for our minecraft
collab for minecraft dungeons and a
check out minecraft dungeons if you want
I've played it now it's very fun so
thanks now as always we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]